It's dark days for democracy.
And our crisis is global.
If you're like me,
you can feel it in your bones.
My expertise focuses on democracy
in the United States,
where I live and work.
And while we've long lifted up
our own system on a pedestal
as an example for the world,
we're one of those democracies
that's currently in a yearslong decline.
So much of the conversation
in the media and among experts
is about our broken two-party system.
Democrats vs. Republicans.
And so much of the conversation
about voting is about the outcomes:
the winners and the losers.
These are the wrong conversations
if we want to tackle the threat
to US democracy today.
Because we have a much more fundamental
challenge, and it’s quickly growing.
The United States election
infrastructure is crumbling.
By infrastructure, I mean the technology,
the physical infrastructure,
like facilities,
and most importantly,
the human infrastructure,
the people who manage
the US voting process.
Election infrastructure is so essential
that it's been designated
critical infrastructure
by the US Department of Homeland Security.
That puts it on par with systems
like our power grid and water supply
in the eyes of the federal government.
But they haven't invested
in it like it's critical.
The average portion of a county budget
spent on election operations
is about half of one percent.
To put that into context,
we spend about the same amount
to maintain parking facilities
as we do our election system.
If we zoom out a little bit,
the US election system is actually
pretty unique by global standards.
Unlike some other places,
we have no central election authority
that's responsible for managing
the logistics of voting
for our entire country.
Instead, we have thousands
and thousands of local departments
that each have some independent mix
for figuring out how to make
voting work where they live.
These departments are staffed
by professional election officials
with support from volunteer poll workers
during peak election season.
So with no government-run how-to
for how to administer elections,
we end up seeing widely different
voting experiences throughout the US,
where voting can legitimately work
one way in one community
and look totally different somewhere else.
For over a decade,
my work has focused on providing
technology and training
and other resources
to state and local election officials
to support them
in their work serving voters.
In my current role,
that has looked like working
with election departments
in every corner of the country,
that together serve about 75 percent
of our eligible voters.
This has given me a really unique window
into what it actually takes
these public servants on the front lines
to do things like
keep voter rolls up to date
and quickly and accurately count ballots
and inform their communities
about how the process works.
This year-round work is hard.
And it's often super thankless.
And the last two years
have been some of the worst.
Election officials
who serve millions of voters
currently lack the basic technology
that they need to reliably do their work.
It either doesn’t exist,
or it’s shockingly outdated.
In the year 2020,
we supported a small New England town
replace their hand crank ballot box
that they had been using
since the early 1900s to count ballots.
One was literally
held together by duct tape.
Even worse,
the people that underpin
our voting process,
the election officials,
are currently under attack.
In exchange for being outspoken
about the integrity of the process
that they managed in 2020,
which, by the way,
turned out to be our highest turnout
election in the US in over a century
and the most secure election
ever administered in our history,
according to our national
security community --
(Applause)
In exchange for the grit and determination
that it took to make that possible
during a global pandemic,
today, election officials
are receiving death threats,
their children are being bullied,
and some have had to flee their homes.
A recent survey shows
that one in three election officials,
one in three,
currently feel unsafe doing their work.
It's appalling.
And enough is enough.
We are at a tipping point for US democracy
and frankly, democracy globally.
I don't know about you,
but I personally don't feel comfortable
just standing around,
leaving things to chance.
And I especially don't feel comfortable
standing by, asking election officials
to keep figuring out
how to make it work alone,
while our system is getting
pushed to its brink.
We need to rally around a set
of shared values and standards,
a North Star,
so that every single voter,
regardless of their zip code,
has access to a process
that's both fair and trustworthy.
Election officials need a place
where they can come together
to keep their skills fresh
so that they're ready to tackle
whatever challenges might come,
whether it's training
to bolster cybersecurity
or to combat disinformation
or to help them keep voters
safe during a pandemic.
And every election department,
rural, urban, large, small,
needs access to 21st century
secure technology
so that every single community
has access to the basics.
Like, a website where voters
can find out answers
about how voting works where they live.
Or data-driven tools
that election officials can use
to make sure that we don't have lines
that snake around city blocks
outside of polling places.
Last summer,
I was at my first conference
since the start of the pandemic,
and I was going up the escalator
and I locked eyes
with this election official
who I absolutely adore.
Let's call her Sarah.
I ran and I gave Sarah a huge hug,
and I realized that probably 60 seconds
passed before we let go.
And when we did, I was crying
and so was Sarah.
Sarah's life got flipped totally upside
down after the 2020 election,
when a vicious conspiracy theory
about her office went viral.
Almost immediately,
the death threats started to roll in,
and they were unrelenting
and they were very specific
about the harm that they wished upon Sarah
and her husband
and their children.
And still, Sarah never backed down
from telling the truth
about the process that she led.
In that moment, I was so overwhelmed
with gratitude and love
and admiration for Sarah
that I couldn't help the tears.
But I think if I'm being
super, super honest,
I was just so happy
that my friend was still here to hug.
Election officials deserve a warm,
welcoming community where their hard
work is celebrated and encouraged,
not vilified.
And all of this is exactly
why I'm so excited
that we are inviting every single
election department in the United States
to join the US Alliance
for Election Excellence.
(Applause)
The Alliance is a place where election
officials and technologists
and designers and other experts
are working hand in hand
to revitalize US democracy.
And we're doing it by focusing
on the basics, a shared North Star,
the tools that it actually takes
to get the job done,
and a community of support
that has each other's back,
whatever might come.
It is absolutely crucial that we rebuild
the foundation of US democracy,
and that's exactly what we're going to do.
The Alliance is not only ready
to meet this moment,
we're ready to create
a foundation so strong,
that we can make it another 200 years.
Together.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)